travailler le cuir c'est devenu la
passion de raphaël cet ancien designer
automobile est aujourd'hui en alternance
chez louis vuitton
le reste du temps ils se forment ici
dans les ateliers de la lizaine depuis
donc maintenant six ans j'ai commencé
par le sait à peine maroquinerie ensuite
l'école boudard qui est des colères metz
pour ensuite arriver aujourd'hui en bts
de maroquinerie est l'objectif
l'objectif c'est d'être metteur au point
dont deux travaillent au développement
de nouveaux produits et leur mise en
industrialisation
comme lui une cinquantaine d'élèves
suivent un cursus dans ce nouveau centre
de formation un centre qui répond à une
demande du monde de la maroquinerie
plusieurs grandes entreprises de la
région cherchent en effet à recruter
comme hermès qui possède trois
manufacture dans le nord franche comté à
base de l'emploi il y en a ça c'est
clair c'est la maroquinerie je sais pas
si vous avez vu un peu les chiffres mais
la maroquinerie vraiment en pleine
expansion donc il ya aucun problème sur
l'employabilité une fois les formations
terminée et puis en général les jeunes
trouvent
trouve des entreprises qui veulent bien
les prendre on travaille bien avec les
pièces avec hermès sont des entreprises
qui prennent des des personnels avec
l'école boudard implanté au cfa de
bethoncourt
ce nouveau centre vient compléter
l'offre de formation est essentielle
pour développer cette filière
d'excellence
ce qui est important c'est d'avoir un
cluster comme on l'a ici dans le pays de
montbéliard et un système de formation
qu'ils soient performants et qu'ils
puissent aussi aller au delà du du ceap
et maroquinerie qu'on puisse former
aussi des gens qui commencent à rentrer
dans la partie jean herring du métier
pour pouvoir développer plus rapidement
être plus efficace parce que nos clients
attendent bien sûr beaucoup d'agilité
notre pas en tout près de 180 personnes
seront ainsi formés chaque année de quoi
faire de montbéliard l'une des
références françaises dans le secteur du
cuir